The joe rogan experience.
So,
uh,
are you digging doing this podcast?
Are you kidding me?
On Fire?
Oh Man,
I'm loving it.
I'm having,
well let's put it that way.
I love doing it.
It's a royal pain in the ass that he search.
Cause will your podcast much like Dan Carlin's is very different.
I always feel ashamed calling my podcast a podcast cause it's just you sit down
and talk but yours is like,
it's an audio lesson on history and in depth audio lesson on like very extreme
aspects of history ea gets and you know that pirate I enjoy because the
storytelling part is awesome.
You Guy whose penis story and make it exciting,
connected with pop culture,
do something that's fun.
That's the part that I love is the month prior to that of just brutal research.
Just comb,
been through boring historical book after boring historical books to find those
little nuggets that are amazing.
Yeah.
And then spin it into a narrative that's the part that gets a little old
sometimes where you're like,
man I do.
I really need to read 200 hours of stuff for this one thing.
It's like that's a lot.
Yeah.
I can only imagine now when you do that,
when you're going over,
combing over all these different uh,
history books and all these different papers written on various times,
do you,
are you like extracting chunks and like putting them in Microsoft word and then
going over it and then like how did you form it?
The question is kind of like do form it as a script or how much of it,
so everything is completely written out.
Not exactly because otherwise they need sound like sound like yard guy or to
getting this thing going and it's boring.
It doesn't sound right.
I just take super extensive notes.
Kind of like if you were to give a lecture that you have never given,
you're not going to sit down and read it by you are going to,
you know,
you have something to keep you on track to make sure it's like,
oh,
where am I going next?
Okay,
great.
There's nothing.
So it's a as a detailed as possible without turning 18 to a that I guy or ed
niece page type of stuff.
Yeah.
I mean history is such a fucking awesome subject because people are crazy and
throughout history people have done so many crazy things and it's just,
it's,
it's such a great thing to know like when you,
if you only had today,
like if we only had our current era and we're looking around how fucking
maniacal people are,
how crazy the world is,
we'd be like,
God,
how did this happen?
How did we get here?
And then you just listened to your podcast and you go,
oh,
this shit's been going on forever.
Seriously.
This is the good tosh.
Exactly this in case you are welding that in good times and yes,
there's much to complain about and yes there's much we can do better without a
doubt,
ladies and gentlemen.
But this is his fucking good as it's ever been by far,
the human psyche is a very weird place because there's so much amazing stuff
that human being stupid or just so much.
And then there's the amount of horror that can be unleashed throughout heat that
has been,
at least through our history by people against other people is just insane.
Yeah.
What is like when you go back and you,
you go over history,
what is the most confusing or disturbing era?
He,
ana to me is not so much at biotech will our period because the same patterns
emerge a lot of the times at different points in time.
Ease a is more,
it was moments,
you know,
when,
uh,
when mob mentality takes over because the reality is the average person is not,
I don't have the award of view where I think the average person,
he's evil.
I don't think that,
I think the average person is weak,
which means that when a inequity nations where everybody's pushing in one
direction is very easy to jump on the bandwagon and in some cases then Yvette
already ordinary human being can do horrible actions.
You meet them for dinner and you think pleasant person good enough,
but you put them in the wrong context and every scene turns to shit I just did.
Um,
I just finished right now it is to power.
See is less,
probably the most disturbing.
I now I want to do what podcast about flowers and puppies cause test one was
heavy.
Man I need the city has on kind of compare and contrast on the sand creek
massacre of the Cheyenne in Colorado in the 1860s and then me lie in Vietnam in
1968 and actually I split it because I had id design critique and they had um,
this guy,
Daryl Cooper was the martyrmade podcast is an amazing podcast there and he
covered me lie and that in the third APP is,
or we're going to sit down and kind of chat about what does this all mean about
the human nature.
Why do the reason why that particular story in those two stories interests me is
because it's too brutal massacre of civilians.
But in both cases that are soldiers who refuse to participate or actually try to
stop it.
They're not the majority.
They are a minority,
but they are there and they try.
So it's not just a story of people do we not ugly stuff.
It's like what?
He's that make one guy when or there,
hey go shoot that three year old,
the one guy goes,
yes sir,
and does it and the next guy goes,
no,
that's not what we are.
Screw you.
I'm not doing that.
That's what interests me is like the individual element of what make people in
the exact same circumstances.
One person go down a really dark path than somebody else instead of having the
balls to say no,
that's not what I am.
That's not what we do with the native American masker.
What,
who was,
how many people were the ones that refuse because you never hear about that.
Oh you hear about it.
They're horrific actions of the soldiers.
Yeah.
Which was the majority.
But there was also like,
there was this one guy,
um,
what's a guy named c Silas soul.
He was told about the guy with [inaudible] cause the guy,
he and the capital of other officers or refuse to let the man under them cause
they were divided in different companies.
So they are companies,
they say no or not participating in this.
This is just straight up slaughter.
These guys are not even a real targets.
These are a bunch of civilians.
So they refused.
And then Silas sold testified against his commander,
the inquiry.
And Danny was promptly more there shortly after nine.
Wow.
So he's like,
it's a crazy story.
But still to this day,
there are people from the Cheyenne tribe who every year they have a ceremony for
Silas soul because they said it not been for him.
A lot more of us would have died on that day and he did that really brave thing
and pay the price for it.
So,
you know,
if you're looking for heroism,
you can do a lot worse than look at this guy story because that guy was
seriously,
you know,
stand up for his conviction under the most extreme circumstances.
So it can top of,
I admire that dad had to be incredibly difficult to just imagine what those
people were doing.
I mean,
when you hear some of the accounts of the slaughters of native Americans,
it's just terrifying that people can just look at someone and just decide,
that's not a person or that's not us.
This is the other.
They've gotta be eliminated.
So we're just going to kill all these kids and kill all these women.
And it happened all over the country.
I mean there's,
there's two things that happened in native Americans.
One,
the big one is disease.
Sure.
And wasn't on purpose.
There's this big myth that people put,
like they put smallpox and blankets and that's all bullshit,
right?
It's pretty much been proven that they didn't really understand.
But bacteria are diseases.
There's one story that's a possible is not a proven thing during,
cause initially nobody understood bacteria and disease or the first [inaudible]
completely unintentional.
There's one tale about the French and Indian war where during a break,
the buddy shar talking about it saying one of the commander saying,
Hey,
maybe we should give them some blankets from the smallpox hospital back in a
while.
We do know that he suggested it.
We have no proof whatsoever that he was actually done.
So.
So that's probably how the rumor got started,
right.
Problem.
But in most cases would happen is just that the Europeans came over and just
inadvertently introduced native Americans diseases and 90% of them were wiped
out.
Yeah.
That's a crazy number.
If you really stop and think about it,
it's to,
they're probably the most dramatic demographic disaster in human history
because,
you know,
I've never,
before you had a situation where a whole continent was not exposed to a series
of diseases.
And so of course there's no immunity the first time they're exposed.
You know,
you don't need to even have smallpox of Cannes needs on somebody on the next
day,
half of the villages that,
you know.
Yeah.
That's crazy.
It's just,
it's amazing that if,
uh,
a group of people just has not come in contact with something that other people
come in contact with all the time and just God with,
you got a cold,
you'd be fine.
Just have some chicken soup,
take a nap.
Meanwhile,
these people are just dead.
That's just kills them off.
That's probably why aliens don't show up.
It's like those motherfuckers are dirty.
If maybe show up these needle nose and we will,
our whole planet will die.
Or maybe the opposite.
They know they'll kill us.
Maybe they have like some super advanced diseases.
That's the other posts to be.
Yeah,
I guess it's just a immune system thing,
right?
If your immune system's not prepared for it.
So it is,
there's a great book by a guy named Dan Flores.
Um,
well he wrote two,
but one of them actually let me actually,
it was a paper that he wrote about the buffalo and he saying that it's really
interesting because he compares the initial and counters that European settlers
had and European travelers had,
um,
before the native Americans were wiped out.
And they talk about how many animals were on the planes and they make it a
direct account of it.
And then after the Europeans had come in,
90% of the native Americans had been wiped out.
And that's when the buffalo population increased goes through the roof and
you're seeing these gigantic packs of milk wouldn't be packed.
So it hurts,
I guess,
of millions and millions of Buffalo.
And he say that's directly attributed to the lack of predators,
which means lack of native Americans because they were preying on these buffalo
of course,
wasn't it interesting when they talked to,
but when he talked about all of the people that were kidnapped by native
Americans that chose to live with them.
Yep.
And then when they were taken back by the Americans,
by the settlers,
you know,
they were like,
fuck this,
I'm going back and going back to the native Americans.
And they went live with them again.
But no one went the other way,
which is really crazy.
Something not flattered in about the euro American culture of the time.
Yeah.
There's a great Benjamin Franklin.
Cool.
If time I'm going to buck shirt,
cause I don't even remember to big any,
something about no utopia and west tasted savage life and then basically gone to
can be our tool come back to leaving our settlements or something like that.
Yeah.
And I'm like,
yeah,
let's see.
Something about fun.
Yeah.
The way they're living their camping,
right.
There's a hunting and fishing every day and you go back and these assholes are
wearing powdered wigs and banging a wooden mallet on a table for everybody to
pay attention.
Fuck off second,
the louder he is.
But that area here you at,
that's what I read about called shirts,
right?
People spend time with that romanticize native color choices like Whoa,
they are old,
you know,
hug trees and [inaudible] herself to forest.
And I'm like,
well yes and no.
There are like what you mentioned,
right?
If you are capture spacial in the east when like French and Indian war or stuff
like that,
I work going on.
If you are a capture by age getting an ATV that paid one of two things happen,
the good one is that they like you and they decide to adopt you and then you end
up by the police in one of their dead family members.
So like if they lost a brother or a father,
then you become that person for that same purpose.
I see.
That's the weird thing that they did.
It's very weird.
But,
but the thing is,
the adoption process was so thorough that day.
Love you.
Like you're the real deal and you end up feeling like you're part of this family
and you know every works out.
It's every scene.
He's great if they don't like you that they torture you to death of her three
day periods.
So it's saying the phone,
these are the same people,
right?
So they can be the sweetest,
most also be woman's or really messed same culture,
same individuals.
Do you think that's just because people have evolved be dealing with tribal
warfare and just we have to have that switch?
I think he's a cause.
The thing that's interesting about natives is that it wasn't a racial thing.
They adopted anybody,
right?
Didn't matter what skin color you have that they did not have a barrier to.
But there is a beaky insider outsider.
You know,
if you are part of our tribe and you may become part of our tribe,
race doesn't matter.
You can become part of our tribe,
but once you're part of our tribe or one of us,
but if you're now part of our tribe,
then you know the same rules do not apply to you.
You are the other,
you are an enemy.
You are an aim.
That case,
that's when it gets ready.
But older.
Yeah.
Even with other native Americans,
that's the thing that people need to really get an like we especially people
that only have a peripheral understanding of native American culture,
like the reason why sewer called sous.
Cause that's a native American word for enemy.
Yup.
Did they call themselves Lakota people?
Right,
exactly.
So all the other Indians are like fuck these crazy assholes are taking over.
They're the enemy.
Yeah,
totally.
They were just dominating.
Yeah.
It's a,
it's really fascinating when you consider that these people had these hunting
grounds and they were trying to protect and one of the things that they've found
is that there are areas or wildlife thrived and the wildlife thrive in these
like a gray area.
Yes.
Because like this one area would be,
you know,
one native American tribe,
and then there are a hunting grounds.
Went to a specific specified distance.
Yup.
No,
obviously always in conflict,
but then pass,
that was another native American tribes,
but in the middle,
that's where you'd find all the fucking animals,
of course.
Is it like,
I get it,
nobody haunts me.
Or they are worried about killing each other in the danger zone.
So now I thought that's how it is that they figured that out.
Yeah.